we are here in Chinatown almost a year
to the date we were here last year
testing the s22 ultra this time I've got
in my hands the s23 ultra
but this time we're pitting against the
iPhone 14 pro Max low light photography
and video
who is going to win
we don't have a clue it's gonna get ugly
it's gonna get pretty
we're gonna find out who is the winner
at the end of this video Let's Do It
this video is brought to you by Asus
check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space gray durability it
even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
alright so going over the specs once
again on the s23 all chart it's almost
the same as the s22 ultra but instead of
100 megapixel camera you now have a 200
megapixel camera instead of 40
megapixels for the front facing camera
it's down to 12 but
it's improved with the whole dual pixel
system that they got inside of it so
that's very similar to what we have here
in the iPhone 14 pro Max 48 megapixel
camera for its main camera system and
its 12 all the way across and then 12 on
the front as well
let's see how they perform because it's
not just about numbers it's also about
Ai and processing and all that great
stuff a16 bionic processor inside of
this Snapdragon 8 gen 2. it's a beast
who's going to win
let's do it all right first I'm going to
take out the the ultra here and we're
gonna
shoot some lights here we're going to
test flaring
because a lot of times we're not going
to be shooting in ample situations now I
see a little bit of flaring going on
there nothing that JJ Abrams wouldn't uh
shy away from but it looks okay colors
on this don't look as saturated as what
I'm seeing in real life it looks a
little bit more muted here on the screen
but again what you see on the screen is
not always what comes out on the
computer now we're going to take it to
the iPhone 14 pro Max
I would say there's more flaring out of
the iPhone
JJ would be proud
but the colors look a little bit more I
have a little more pop to them put the
edge the s23 ultra for flaring colors
I'll give it to the iPhone
but this is kind of a boring shot but
you know these are situations that we
may be in so now we're going to try out
this scenario here we got this sort of
this neon LED light wall we got this
vending machine here a little bit of
street photography bring out the s22
ultra 200 megapixels mind you because
we're maxing out the resolution
iPhone right here
okay the iPhone decent
a little bit washed out here on the
colors of the lights here now what we're
seeing is more of a purplish blue here
it almost looks white with a little bit
of purple right you just see a little
bit of the flare coming through it
but let's see how the Samsung fares
okay this is much better you definitely
see the colors now the color isn't
accurate to what we're seeing with our
eye it's more purple but you're seeing
the colors in the LED wall you're seeing
the dynamic range here the Shadows the
highlights in the vending machine so
it's exposing for everything it's done a
really good job with a lot of detail
I'm gonna give the win to Samsung
okay now we're going to go to the
front-facing camera because this is the
camera that most of us use most of the
time Instagram reels and Tick-Tock and
all that great stuff so I'm going to do
a photo here and then with the iPhone
good exposure looks good
going
to the s23 ultra
looking at both of these photos right
here real quick
all right the s23 ultra is a lot more
saturated than the iPhone 14 pro Max the
iPhone 14 pro Max looks a little bit
more natural as you can see right here
there is a definite difference in terms
of the color out of this now in terms of
detail
I would say they're about even
slight Edge to the s23 ultra on that
but
I gotta say I think I like the colors of
the iPhone more on this one looks a
little bit more natural more balanced
anyway let's go to video right now let's
test out video on this because both of
these do 4K by the way this is the only
Android phone thus far that does 4K for
the front-facing camera all the other
ones we've tried oh both xiaomi uh Vivo
all of them
do 1080 only so let's have some video
fun here all right we're doing a video
test here on the iPhone 14 pro Max with
a front facing camera in 4k
I believe it's 25 or 30p one of those
will let you know in the comment section
below and now we're going to go to the
Samsung all right we're doing video here
on the Samsung and we are shooting in 4k
as well and I'll say that the image does
look a little bit smoother but this
display is so gorgeous it's kind of hard
to tell we'll have to see on the
computer screen but it does look really
really good seeing a little bit of
flaring coming into play once in a while
but actually this is really well
controlled I say I have to like this
video on this quite a bit
all right looking at both of these
videos I would say this is really tough
to be honest with you they're really
neck and neck
I might say I'd give a little bit of the
edge to the s23 ultra in terms of
sharpness but the iPhone is right there
but in terms of the white balance I'm
going to give it to the iPhone 14 pro
Max I feel does a better job with the
white balance this is just a little bit
too warm a little bit too saturated for
my liking but both are really good and
you don't have them side by side you
probably won't be able to tell the
difference anyway that's it for
front-facing camera now let's do rear
camera for video
all right so we're doing 4K 24p here on
the iPhone 14 pro Max okay now here's
the thing with the s23 ultra if you use
the standard video uh mode in the camera
app you're not going to have access to
more of the specific frame rates let's
say 24
et cetera et cetera et cetera you can
only choose 30 and 60. so I'm using the
pro video mode right now to do this and
we're going to test this out
[Music]
we are recording right now so I'm now
testing the Samsung Galaxy s23 Ultra
here with the pro video mode at 4K 24p
to match the iPhone to see how it
performs of course we were just buying
this loud music happening here so we're
going to see how the microphone picks up
on this which microphone is better it's
going to be a battle up for sure but I
think this is I actually like this app a
little bit more than we see on the
iPhone where you have more control over
your video on the iPhone you don't have
is you have to download a separate app
so I would probably give the edge to the
Samsung in terms of control and
customization but it's all about the
video quality and we're going to see
what they look like right now
oh that's crispy crispy stuff
I've got to tell you Zaki
Samsung on that I got to give the
Samsung nice contrast nice pop good
separation with the background it looks
a lot more professional this video looks
like it could have come out of a aps-c
or even a you know a budget-friendly
full-frame camera system it looks that
good the iPhone tends to be a little bit
too hdr-ish with the video on that and
that's a little bit of a downside which
you really can't you can turn off the
HDR to a point but it's really difficult
um
it kind of just takes control but you
have customization over this and with
this pro video app I'm going to give it
to Samsung when it comes to the video
what do you think Jackie
Samsung yeah Samsung for that let's uh
let's go to somewhere dark Zachy let's
go dark and
dirty I know face
you do yeah
okay okay
let's go I told you it's gonna get ugly
we're gonna go real deep inside
now we're in a we're really in a dark
situation here this is I know you can't
even see me exactly you're going to see
a little bit of glimpses of light with
me right
we're gonna try this this doorway here
let's see if we got night mode here we
have night mode on this let's see how it
captures wow impressive really bumps it
up
okay that's just one test let me bring
out the iPhone again these photos aren't
going to win any awards but we're just
testing things out right now
and uh
yeah
out of these two the Samsung will
definitely pull out more detail because
of the night mode on that
um we do have a night mode on some sort
of you know low light mode on the iPhone
14 pro Max it does a decent job of
balancing the highlights and the Shadows
well this would be kind of cool let's
shoot this
one more time
okay
these are very close to be honest with
you I would give a little bit more
contrast to the iPhone
versus the Samsung but they do both do a
good job of pulling out a lot of details
in a lower light situations due to their
night mode and the way that they expose
so but I would say looking at the phone
screen I probably would give the edge to
the iPhone being a little bit sharper
but we're not done yet we still got more
to shoot this is pretty good right here
there's a rat right there you see that
rat Jackie missed the rat it's right
there don't worry stand right here Zach
I'm gonna take a portrait of you a
little like because you know in these
situations you would take a photo of
somebody right
radius you would
backlight Zaki
not bad does a good job exposing let's
bring out the iPhone
oh
I think we got ourselves a winner here
Zachy I think you're going to notice
this yourself as soon as I show you the
image at first glance I would say the
iPhone
why the face is more exposed now the
back though is a little bit blown out in
the highlights what Samsung has done is
balance the highlights and the Shadows
to give you a really nice image with
dynamic range but if you don't care
about that and you say look I want
something a little bit more natural how
a camera would actually photograph this
then I would give it to the iPhone but
you see the flaring definitely more
flaring coming out of the iPhone than
the Samsung image what do you guys think
you let us know in the comments which
one you prefer this is very interesting
but I got to hand it to Samsung for
really balancing out the highlights and
the shadows and exposing the subject and
this is in portrait mode mind you this
is not a night mode this is in portrait
mode and it does this very impressive
camera system all right Jackie let's go
along well you know what we're going to
the durian stall we're going to find out
how it handles during it now for you
guys who are not from Singapore don't
know where we're talking about durian is
a fruit that you find in Malaysia
Thailand
I think in this part of the world right
Zacky and it smells has a very pungent
smell but it tastes amazing I actually
like Duran I actually like Duran a lot I
like green a lot
oh there it goes
try macro mode as well
we kind of just did a two in one test
with this now looking at this first
glance the Samsung tends to over sharpen
the macro a little bit whereas the
iPhone is a lot more natural in terms of
the macro so this actually looks like a
true macro photo this is macro but over
sharpened so I think the processing is a
little bit too heavy on the Samsung so
I'll hand it to Apple on that one
but still good okay nice colors
decent on
Samsung but I think the detail I would
give it to the iPhone on this I think it
just does a good job capturing it nice
contrast a little more punchier of an
image
um they're very close to mind you okay
they're very close I would say that
there's a little bit more of a bluish
Hue or a cooler uh temperature let me
put it that way cooler temperature on
the Samsung Galaxy s23 where there's a
little bit more of a warmer temperature
on the iPhone 14 pro Max so you know
what interesting about the iPhone 4G Pro
Max in terms of image quality if you
were to match it to a camera system
actually it matches very close to
Nikon's color science so that's
something that we've noticed here geek
culture quite a bit when we've tried to
mix and match iPhone footage with our
Nikon z62 and z72 video files this
matches really well this is a little bit
more cooler and I can warm it up very
easily but that's something to take note
of small thing but we're talking about
the nuances that make these phones
different
[Music]
thank you
all right guys so it's time with Zaki
we're gonna kind of run some video tests
with the iPhone 14 pro pretty much the
same cameras as the pro Max as well as
the Samsung s23 Ultra we're gonna
basically be using Bobby's awesome
Volkswagen rteon
there we go very nice uh we're just
gonna create a montage shooting the 4K
um 50 frames per second or 60 frames per
second if you will get some nice slow-mo
and we are going to do it handheld just
to test the wires as well
um pretty much using the standard lens
when it comes to low light and because
the s23 ultra and the iPhone 14 pro have
a cinematic mode as well we're gonna
test them out so let's hop to it I'm
gonna try and make this as consistent as
I can short for short
and uh we just see how it goes in post
all right go for it show you guys in a
bit
[Music]
foreign
you can kind of tell there are some
drastic differences when it comes to
certain lighting conditions on both
phones that being said the iPhone 14 pro
slash Pro Max we tend to see when it
comes to the default configurations or
default exposures that the iPhone 14 is
trying to get
as much lighting as possible so things
tend to be Overexposed now of course you
can adjust that manually bring the
exposure down a little bit so you can
get something that's less noisy and a
little bit more sharp sharper in the
details right but Samsung s23 man
I mean we've tested the phone last year
the s22 ultra last year and this has a
significant difference if you are
looking for the phone for video
I think this is a very strong Contender
for 2023. final thoughts is Jackie just
kind of talked about in the terms of the
video quality shooting the car here
I gotta head into Samsung for the video
quality overall I think they've done a
really good job with this
um iPhone I'm a huge iPhone fan I love
what Apple does but I gotta say there
are times that the stabilization just
doesn't work it Jitters when it
shouldn't Jitter where the Samsung is a
lot more fluid and I like the more
neutral tones coming out of the
Samsung's camera versus the very warm
tones coming out of iPhones now this is
something you can adjust in post to some
extent but with these camera systems
it's nice to have it out of the gate
right away versus you go after going and
post and editing them but overall I
gotta say this has been a really
interesting battle
um I thought the iPhone would definitely
take this overall and while there's the
ecosystem that Apple has that I think is
superior to what Samsung has overall I
have to say camera for camera the s23
ultra has really impressed me to the
point where I would definitely recommend
it for most people out there probably is
arguably the best Android camera right
now and I'm saying that in February
because there's a lot of stuff coming in
the next couple months so they could
give Samsung a challenge on this but as
of right now in terms of video and also
photography I gotta say Samsung's done a
tremendous job anyway guys let me know
your thoughts which one did you like the
most in the comment section below if you
like this review check out more of our
videos right here